kendall Jenner claps back at a New York
City bar after they accuse her of
sniffing the bartender a lot of it's so
not true
[Music]
over the weekend the 21 year old model
faced some major backlash on social
media when she was accused of not
tipping at babies all right a bar in
Brooklyn on Friday that's so annoying
the bar shared a pic of this signed
receipt on Instagram a $24 tab with a
tip left blank the name on the dotted
line Kendall and Jenner awkward the pic
has since been removed but was captions
quote don't forget to tip your bartender
complete with a smiley face people
lashed out in the comments and on
Twitter to call Kendall out for being
quote cheap that's insane but on Monday
Kendall took to Twitter to set the
record straight writing quote damn I
guess next time we won't tip in cash I'm
freaking out and she has at least one
person on her side older sister Khloe
Kardashian chimed in quoting Kendall's
tweet and writing quote people are
pathetic it's always something
[Music]
you